good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
studying today is scp-1004 object class
safe special containment procedures all
copies of scp-1004 1 and 2 are to be
kept in secure containment locker 17 at
site 37 at no point are any copies of
scp-1004 to be used for recreational
purposes following the events of
incident 1004 tale researchers are no
longer allowed to view the output of
scp-1004 even when filtered or by a
secondary source only d-class are
allowed to view the output of scp-1004
use of SCP 11 33 - 7 and SCP 894
instances by researchers and control
subjects has been approved were deemed
appropriate in preventing undesired
spread of scp-1004 effects the
Foundation has set out to prevent anyone
from receiving copies of scp-1004 by a
planned and ordered process of
unrequested electronic mailings many of
which include computer viruses malware
or electronic worms a program has also
been designed and disseminated to all
electronic mail providers to help
prevent scp-1004 from spreading
description scp-1004 is a computer
program found on either a CD scp-1004 -
- or a 3.5 inch diskette scp-1004 - one
either of which will be hand labelled
with the words factory porn contained on
these discs is a single executable file
labeled the factory Exe a 1 kilobyte
program the program runs perfectly on
all platforms running the program
results in a window opening on the
computer within which the factory logo
is displayed
logo fades to black and is replaced by
the words what would you like to see at
this point the user may input any
selection of words from the ambiguous to
the precise once a request has been
input the program will pull up several
dozen images of pornographic content
each of which leads to a full video on
the subject many of these videos appear
to never have been made in real life
watching videos on a CP 1004 have a
cumulative effect the more pornography a
user views the more disturbing their
sexual desires become and the harder
sexual gratification becomes after
approximately 100 straight hours of
viewing pornography on scp-1004 even the
most normal viewers will display an
interest in scatology play the torture
and murder of living beings best eality
pedophilia and combinations of the
previous the deadening of reactivity to
sexual gratification will encourage them
to either seek out such things in real
life or seek to mutilate themselves and
their genitalia it should be noted that
scp-1004 displays no compulsive
properties users are free at any time to
stop using the program the majority of
users continue to use scp-1004 because
it is the easiest way to find the
desired pornography as stated above any
word or combinations of words may be
entered this has been used by many
victims to view popular members of high
social standing in the bedroom
giving rise to many rumors of celebrity
sex tapes
the thought has been posited that such
videos could be used for the
blackmailing of politicians who are
antithetical to the foundation cause
unfortunately at this time all attempts
to make recordings of a-c-p 10:04 have
resulted in only taped static several
researchers have claimed to be able to
see humanoid shapes moving in the static
but this effect has not been seen on
subsequent playthroughs scp-1004 appears
to spread through the use of electronic
messages sent seemingly at random
messages generally claim to have certain
celebrities performing sexual acts or to
have certain depraved acts on tape that
are illegal in many jurisdictions a link
included in the message requests users
to enter their home address the
resulting copy of scp-1004 show up in a
plain brown wrapper within 3 days
through bulk mail with no return address
the foundation currently contains 37
copies of scp-1004 - one and twenty
three copies of scp-1004 - two incident
1004 dale researcher adam Dale was found
to be encouraging d-class subjects to
watch scp-1004 and to copulate with each
other for his pleasure it was determined
researcher Dale had been affected by a
CP 1004 despite never having watched it
directly only monitoring the tests
through a video feed any and all
indirect viewing of scp-1004 has been
cancelled okay well that was
uncomfortable I'm gonna go very quickly
now thanks for listening and you were
all dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to Andre Pichette Pierce M
Hamlin Muslim Wookiee Jax Merrick caleb
bowen slump god John Porter captain
Gorge Tiber ball cody tench
cheese whip dips McGee and doctor mortis
thank you so much for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos found some other cool
stuff as well go to patreon.com/scishow
thank you
[Music]
you